what is the difference between mass and
weight I think it's something that a lot
of people are confused about they just
think that anything that's big like this
car has a lot of weight it's very heavy
it's got a lot of mass and people just
basically think of these ideas as all
the same but there's an important
distinction between the terms mass and
weight mass refers to the amount of
matter in an object whereas weight is a
force it's the gravitational attraction
that the object feels towards in this
case the Earth's center so I've got a
little experiment today where I brought
my car out here and ask some people why
is it difficult to push my car and my
bet is their answer will be because the
car is heavy you gonna say heavy it's a
pencil but I'm the or down hill but you
know the cars heavy big rock you would
think would be heavy anything to speak
you would think would be heavy too heavy
oh it's bit lighter than I thought it's
got its weight weight is responsible
what is weight weight is massive in a
gravity what is this gravity thing
gravity is what I hate full of the core
of the earth your car is pulled towards
it at the center of the earth yes but
now when you push it let's say you're
pushing your car you're not pushing it
up you know I mean but it's still hard
to push yeah so do you think weights
responsible for making it hard to push
well it is white I mean like a lot of
the counties used to push so yeah like
weight and the exhibiter gravity on the
mat but I'm not trying to lift the car
right I'm just trying to push it like
that big rock you would think would be
heavy anything to speak you would think
would be heavy so Chi but I'm not
lifting it I'm pushing it so also
gravity of it I suppose but this is this
is my question right yeah but I'm not
trying to lift it no that's true but
it's still it's still hard to push so
why is that because like if I lift it I
understand you saying it's heavy yeah
and it would be really hard but we're
pushing
and we're actually getting it to go so
how does that work
the answer is because the car has
inertia inertia means that objects with
mass have a tendency to resist changes
in their motion I thought she had a
great answer when I started which was
inertia can you tell us about that what
is what scenarios like wants something
stopped it doesn't really want to go and
when something's going doesn't matter
yeah well the idea that I'm trying to
get at is there's actually two different
things right one thing is that there's a
force pulling this down into the earth
and that's what we call weight and that
makes it impossible to lift but there's
something else which is called inertia
and that means something is difficult to
change its motion the car's got a lot of
inertia and that's why it's difficult to
push which is different than why it's
difficult to lift which is the weight
force pulling it down towards the earth
fair enough but it's actually not as
difficult to push it it's not that hard
yeah I know it doesn't even prove my
point because I push it with one hearing
K yeah